[Applause]
[Music]
hello
and welcome to trigonometry i'm francis
foster
i'm constantly kissing and this is a
show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people
our brilliant guest today is a professor
of political science
at portland state university bruce
gilley welcome to trigonometry
thank you thank you for having me it is
great to have you here
we obviously have met before but other
people may not know who you are
tell everybody who are you how are you
where you are
what has been your journey through life
that brings you here
uh well i'm a uh political scientist as
you said
and uh i just was a journalist before i
left journalism and
went into the academy and
ended up here in beautiful portland
since i'm from uh western canada my
wife's from california so this was more
or less the midpoint
and i work in comparative politics
international relations
international development issues and i'm
best known because
i wrote an article in 2017 called the
case for colonialism
which apparently i was not supposed to
write because apparently that's
offensive
and there is no case for colonialism so
i was canceled
in the sense that the journal that
published that article in 2017
was facing death threats to editorial
staff so i agreed to
have it withdrawn and now i've been
canceled again because
a biography of a british colonial
official sir alan burns that was uh
actually shipping the stores already was
cancelled last week
because a maoist leonardist mark zedong
mao zedong theorist
in toronto also decided that that was
inappropriate that that should be read
and so here i am
well it's good to have you here uh it
seems our list of guests increasingly
includes people who have been cancelled
as that phenomenon spread and obviously
we've had nigel bigger one of your
colleagues on the show who
who was himself canceled for defending
your article
uh in in a times piece as well so we've
talked to him about that but
before we get into the the the stuff
about
cancel culture and free speech and the
ability for academics to
debate ideas uh what is the case for
colonialism exactly because colonialism
now seems to be
sort of it's like it's like writing an
article saying the case for nazism to
many people
yeah the case for colonialism is that
colonialism
not only made people better off
more free it allowed them to live
survive
boosted survival rates
access to food water protected
minorities
from human rights violations especially
women
that's what i would call the objective
side of it but i think the real
dirty laundry in the closet of most
colonial
writing is it was legitimate too the
people
supported it by and large which is why
colonial governments
had practically no colonial officials on
the ground
colonialism was mainly carried out by
the people living in the places
and that's what i call the legitimacy
argument so those are the two
two key pieces we could go on ad nauseum
i have a 40 page bibliography of
research that supports that conclusion
and i understand that many people
disagree and they should
and we should be engaged in constant
debates on this
um and i don't expect it will end
anytime soon
the question is um what does it say
about a school of thought
when it's afraid to hear counter
arguments
well the speaking of the counter
arguments a lot of people who've
have studied history perhaps not very
much but have studied it would say
well what about the treatment of
starting with let's say take
christopher columbus arrival in in north
america and central america
uh the treatment of the of the locals
there the treatment of the native
americans
from there on in the british empire's
conquests
and oppression of people around the
world uh
obviously slavery translated
trans-atlantic slave trade
uh the conquistadors in south america
surely all of that was bad bruce you
wouldn't challenge that would you
i would actually um so first of all
um most of what has been built up as
uh kind of a constant depression
starting with columbus um
was anything but columbus was actually
very sensitive too
to the locals um there's a new article
you may have seen in the spectator
showing
um you know that this this was a this
was a settlement that was
highly restrained for the time yes did
he have kind of
consultative committees and recycling
programs no
but for the time and certainly compared
to
the cultures that were otherwise likely
to show up in these places
it was by far the most enlightened and
human rights sensitive
form of encounter between civilizations
the world has known
and i would say that's generally like as
a general statement true
about not just the british empire
because the british empire is easy it's
easy to defend the british empire i
would say this applies to
the portuguese empire this applies to
the germans i have a book coming out on
german colonialism in about a month
we'll probably be back here because
there'll be another cancelled war over
that
um but you know my argument is colonial
scholarship is basically a train wreck
and 50 years of ignorance have been
produced by the academy
and it's going to take a lot of work to
recover an authentic objective
evidence-based account of colonialism
was there a lot of bad stuff
that happened during which half of the
globe was ruled by five countries
billions of people over hundreds of
years and billions of interactions of
course there was
but this is called selection bias when
we find out those little incidents
and then decide that they invalidate the
entire experience i don't know of a
single case and i again i would say
not a single case where we would say the
people
would have been better off had the
colonialists not arrived
and taking into account also you know
the the horrific things that happened in
these places
both before colonialism arrived what
would have happened had a different set
of colonizers shown up which almost
certainly would all
also been uh gun-toting westerners but
without the accountability
to governments that actual imperialism
had and
the great historical amnesia what
happened after the colonialists were
suddenly forced out
not a pretty picture over the last 50
years do you think part of the problem
is bruce is that you
you make a case for colonialism and in a
lot of people's heads what they think is
that you're making a case for slavery
yeah or genocide or you know what about
so i call this the what about arguments
right well what about the what about the
mao mao
what about the herrero what about the
majimaji rebellion what about tasmania
right and so this is this is kind of
what i call what about ism so there's
two answers to what about ism
yes a lot of bad stuff happened and
there's no excuse for it and it was a
failure of accountability mechanisms
sure great
um the second question is though i often
look into these what abouts more
carefully
and i discover there's not much what
about to be found there
so as i said i have a book coming out on
german colonialism i spent a lot of time
talking about the herrera nama
wars in german southwest africa as well
as the majimaji rebellion in german east
africa
these two things are supposedly
irrefutable evidence
for why german colonialism was a
terrible thing and i find both claims
empty
now people will disagree with me i have
no problem with that
i draw upon the scholarship of many
people who do agree with me
that's part of what we do in academia um
so
you know the bigger issue is why are we
so scared to have these debates
why is the mere mention of an opposing
viewpoint
you know reason to rush to the cancel
culture office and
instigated an investigation uh bruce i'm
english you don't have to persuade me
that the germans were dreadful
but well yes well to that point
uh you know much of the the
uh twisted and unfair historiography
about german colonialism began with the
british at the treaty of versailles the
british
which was which is a real violation of
the british empirical tradition and the
british
blue book tradition the blue books were
of course their annual reports on
colonies
well they drew up a blue book on german
colonialism in order to justify
the seizure of german colonies at
versailles it was a
real violation of that british empirical
objective tradition and a sad chapter in
british
in british imperial rule and foreign
policy because
much of what was produced by the british
essentially for propaganda purposes at
versailles
became entrenched in the historiography
about german colonialism
eagerly lapped up by the far left and
east german scholars who of course we
know were absolutely in a position to
engage in objective research
and has become kind of uh locked in
in a way that is going to take just a
massive effort to undo
so there you go man it's all your fault
and your far left very good
and that's what i keep telling him
anyway bruce uh but
it's let me ask you this because
uh i'm just curious actually what is uh
why is it important to uh
have this different view of colonialism
to the one that's being pushed at the
moment why is that significant
so that's that's a great question
constantine and you know frankly
uh everyone from my wife on up around me
will tell me
why are you doing this you're causing
you're causing yourself trouble you're
causing your family trouble
you're hated by your colleagues in your
department who
spend a lot of time trying to find ways
to drive me out
um you're called a white supremacist you
know is this worth it
like you know why why why are you so
engaged in this so
part of my answer is well i'm an
academic my job is to
seek the truth as best i see it and
pursue those research topics that i find
interesting so that's not very
convincing to my wife
so i think i think the bigger issue is
and i think this is what where it really
is coming back to is
um you think it's just about
the herrero or you think it's just about
the mao mao
or the question of you know
the uh anglo anglo-egyptian condominium
over the sudan and some obscure
historical issue
it's not because the whole rhetoric
about the evils of colonialism has now
become
the rhetoric about decolonize now the
decolonize
is probably coming soon to a theater
near you
it may be already in your workplace uh
and what is decolonized in then in a
nutshell
decolonizes an attack on the
enlightenment and on science
and reason it argues that the basis on
which liberal civilization has arisen
is a fraud and we need to dismantle it
so we will no longer for instance be
promoting our colleagues in the academy
based on their research records
but we'll be all adopting alternative
approaches to
promotion such as whether their friends
think they're great people
or whether they've made a big
contribution
to the latest social justice movement uh
tearing down the downtown
right so this is to me there's a there's
a lot more at stake here than just
um obscure debates about history
and i got into this with the germans
because one of the big issues in
contemporary german foreign policy
is should germany be engaged
in paying massive reparations to the
people of contemporary namibia
maybe tanzania maybe cameroons and togo
where they were former colonial rulers
and the arguments in favor of that say
well look at how terrible it was
for the germans to be colonizers here so
there's something at stake here not just
in terms of uh
contemporary culture and workplace and
scientific enlightenment values but
in terms of real policy implications is
you know there's demand for reparations
and reparations assume harm was
committed if no harm was committed then
uh policymakers need to know that and
what do you say bruce to those people
who say look that these empires were
fundamentally racist
it was basically white people going over
to countries where they were brown
people enslaving them
uh taking you know their natural
resources transporting them making them
more impoverished and enriching
uh the white countries uh well yes they
were racist of course they were racist
because everyone was a racist back then
so that's a totally anachronistic
argument for one
um what's the interesting question is um
in terms of the degree of racism let's
say if we could measure it
um how racist were they and i would say
they were the most unracist
examples of governance the world has
ever seen especially compared to
the racism that most subject peoples had
experienced
from the dominant tribes in their in
their territories of course
this is how colonialism spread it spread
because groups which were facing
annihilation
or enslavement or extinction by major
rival groups whether it was
the buganda in east africa
whether it was the major black tribes
moving into south
africa and displacing and enslaving the
coisians the so-called hottentots um
right that that yeah um
maybe that maybe they wouldn't let you
into their clubs to have gnts at the end
of the day but the other
threat to you was the people who wanted
to actually make you their slaves
and uh ship you off maybe two places
where slavery remains so
so racism is relative and it's
historically embedded
so to to go through some colonial
officials memoirs from
1832 and find some unkind comments on
the locals and then say aha you see
these things were a complete disaster
for people's
is uh i mean it's bad history and it's
bad logic and it's bad philosophy and
we know that the reason why these
empires found
such a ready welcome by and large from
most places they were
otherwise they couldn't have stayed
there is because people experienced them
as less racist than the rivals there's a
great book called baba of cairo done by
a british anthropologist felice smith
1945 it was issued and baba of cairo
talks very explicitly about
you know did i want to be subject to the
fulanis the slave empire
that enslaved us and stole our daughters
or did i want to be
under the rule of the british who really
just wanted us to stop killing each
other and were willing to pay us
if we worked for them hey i'll take the
racist british if that's what you want
to call them over the racist fulani and
i think in all circumstances
you know this this was the concrete
choice and it just seems to me
stunningly arrogant and anachronistic
for some academic in a western
university
sitting there with as much food and
security
and running water and safety from
enslavement and major human rights
violations
to tut those people facing concrete
choices of life and death
for having accepted or acceded to
western colonial rule
uh i was going to say bruce neither of
us is qualified to assess the
the merits of the historical argument
there but one of the things that
as a layman i would say is you know
francis and i were just on holiday in
sicily in this
in the island of the southern uh tip of
italy
and that is a part of the mediterranean
that was conquered
repeatedly by different groups and
tribes over over the centuries
and every monument that we went to see
over the course of two weeks
the guide would explicitly say you know
the carthaginians
defeated the greeks they used the greek
slaves to build this temple
and then 100 years later the greeks came
back and they used the carthaginian
slaves to build this temple
and then the romans came and they
enslaved both the carthaginians and the
greeks
and they built this thing here and it's
a sort of universal constant through
history why do you think we now
seem to be just obsessed with this idea
of slavery as this unique sin of modern
western civilization when in fact
it was a constant through through
history i mean that is one thing that if
anyone who has
any superficial understanding of history
would tell you
uh because white people love it when
it's
all about them and that is
the essence of eurocentrism i mean it is
comical to see these radical scholars
decla you know arguing against
eurocentric um
knowledge and eurocentric systems when
their whole
intellectual apparatus is to put the
white man at the center and to keep him
there
right and so you know you read like uh
in these people who talked a lot about
the shelby steel his book white guilt
talks about this with respect to united
states you know
the need for white people to feel guilty
uh which is a very uh christian uh
response
to the world through guilt to seek
uh to seek some form of benediction
some form of absolution and through that
process of guilty feeling
and absolution seeking to therefore
therefore be redeemed
and then in christian eschatology of
course none of these people are
christians but they're they're operating
with a fully christian template
to therefore have attained moral
superiority over others
so what is this this is about trying to
reestablish
white moral superiority over other
people it is
to summarize racist right uh to to
to to claim that the lives and histories
of other people
have not been through their own choices
their own agency
their own cultural repertoire through
the things that have happened to them
and through which they have been active
agents but to say no no no no it's it's
about me it's about
us right is the embodiment
of white supremacy so you know this is
why we know these arguments now about
how wokeness and white supremacy
you know in terms of that that circle
you know really
share a lot of fundamental premises um
and i think you see it
in this argument there's a um there's a
funny argument that's uh
thomas soule the great stanford
economist says you know we look at
eastern europe and western europe um
you know what was the difference why did
western europe take off well because the
western europeans were conquered by the
romans
um and the uh and the eastern europeans
weren't
and thereby the western europeans got
the latin alphabet
and um you know the rest is history so
to speak
so do the western europeans
feel resentment against the romans is
there kind of
um historical animosity about the roman
empire in western europe no
and it's not just because they realized
that the roman empire
had very clear developmental benefits
but also it's because
why would you give up your historical
agency to
a narrative about victimization because
we don't want it to be about the romans
and it's not about the romans as a
historical matter you know history
takes place through the active agency of
those through which
history affects them and there's a
bigger apparatus here at work
through which the attempts to pull
slavery and colonialism that were
practiced by western colonies out of its
historical context and make it
anachronistic
evidence of white guilt is part of an
attempt to resurrect the centrality
of the white man in world history and
you know
i think tarthankar roy who is one of the
people who blurbed my cancelled book
wrote a letter to the publisher who
canceled it and his letter has been
widely circulated because he says to
to the publisher you know we people
in south asia and africa are tired of
white people telling us what we can and
cannot read
um that is the essence of white
supremacy
um stop trying to control our history
with your white guilt syndrome
the us election is coming up and you
might be wondering what makes people
vote for donald trump
racism obviously that's a joke guys
as you know a lot of people even from
minority backgrounds are considering
voting for donald trump
this time round and we saw a movie the
other day which was just
amazing talking about this very issue
it's got a very nice ambivalent subtle
title
gotta love trump but don't be put off
it's actually a great film
and actually really explores the reasons
why
people and particularly those from an
ethnic minority background voted for
donald trump
it's a great movie and if you want to
watch it as a trigonometry fan
you get a 33 discount absolutely not
even the donald would disagree with that
take advantage of this fantastic offer
head over to the website which is
invictus dash tv dot com and the code is
trigger kk ff 2020 that's two case
absolutely and we want to reemphasize
that that's two case
trigger kk ff 2020
and enjoy god i love trump
so but bruce answer me this how should
we deal
with you know i've put it in the context
of sicily and other countries as well of
course
that civilizations have done terrible
things
forever that is human nature it's
inescapable
the moment you open a history book
you're immediately confronted with
uh all sorts of you know human behavior
that is abhorrent
and it's inevitable and there's no doubt
the the colonial powers
and the people that they whose land they
came to to rule
all of them were involved in this how
should we look should we not ever feel
guilt for anything that was done in the
past should we just go oh no that was
par
and parcel of the time there's nothing
wrong with genocide there's nothing
wrong with
to taking millions of people from africa
putting them on on slave ships in which
they suffer and drown and die of hunger
and malnutrition
there's nothing wrong with that that was
par for the course is that how we should
look at things surely we should have a
bit more
uh more sort of contrition about things
shouldn't we
okay two issues constantine first of all
constantine how many black people have
you enslaved in your life
uh well i don't want to say on camera
zero and francis how many peop how many
brown people's land have you stolen
and then sold them into uh abject
poverty i'm a millennial i can't even
afford property bruce
right right so i mean honestly just as a
starting point that's a horrible
horrible uh
even pre-modern form of thought
that one would describe wrongs
done by a to b merely because
b shares a similar genitalia or skin
tone
or heritage i mean that that's a very
dangerous form of philosophy if you
think about it
uh chinese people in the united states
are sometimes scapegoated now because of
covet um
that's a horrible thing they did nothing
to do
with covet in fact most people in china
had nothing to do with covet so that
that is like
uh i don't want to call that old
testament because it's not fair to the
old testament but
you know what people think of this is
this is the the blood debt
that you inherit by virtue of some vague
association
to people who may or may not have done
bad things in the past so let's
let's stop that right away right that is
dangerous and evil
the second question is yes we by all
means
in history engage in examination
of good things and bad things that
happened as a result of
people's actions at different times of
the past great that's that's our
that's that's what we do right we look
at history we try and objectively assess
the good and the bad
what i would say is again we have to
always
keep in mind at two things and this is
uh you know this is just social science
and i think a lot of historians because
history has moved towards the humanities
in the last decades
historians don't actually know what it
means to conduct scientific research
so i always say three things first of
all
counter factuals right you cannot say
this was terrible you know as a
meaningful statement
unless you are pretty sure that in the
absence of the forces that led that to
happen
the people's well-being whatever
happened would not have been less
terrible okay now that's
hardly difficult to do uh but actually
we can do counter factual
thought experiments especially when we
have side by side places for instance
one of which was colonized one of which
was not would you rather be a resident
of contemporary haiti or would you
rather be a resident of contemporary
bahamas
okay bahamas is a counterfactual to
haiti okay so we can do that kind of
thing counterfactual secondly controls
people uh who studied colonialism
recently um and then you know think um
frederick cooper as probably the best
known for saying this is you know
colonialism wasn't really a thing in the
sense that
pretty much everything that happened to
non-western areas
during the area of western imperialism
would have happened anyway
why because so much of those forces
economic social technological uh
geographic the spread of disease burdens
this would have all happened with or
were not with or without columbus or
lord lugard
right i mean western europe was
expanding
and mainly through privateers and
colonialism was
anime is an attempt to govern that
encounter in a way that would be
better for both parties so controls
super important you know that's the the
controls meaning the other things that
were also happening at the same time
counterfactuals controls and finally
case selection don't cherry pick your
evidence right whenever you measure
something
which is for instance how long did that
rule last
um how many rebellions were there right
you need to have a proper understanding
of how we
conceptualize and then measure something
like rebellion it turns out when you
scratch a little below the surface of
most of this history
what is today called a resistance
against the west or
anti-colonial rebellion or or self you
know emancipatory struggle
it turns out none of these struggles had
anything to do with that it was usually
you know we don't like this tax
or could you please help me to expand
and uh
you know take over my neighbor's land i
mean these these were
these have been back these have been
back casted at a as kind of
um as struggles against things that we
later invented and decided were wrong so
that's just
that's just bad history right and so
many of these issues that we talk about
there's no attention paid to controls
counterfactuals and case selection and
yes i'm sorry i'm boring you
because this is what social scientists
do but but so many of the historical
critiques i get
come from people who i don't think could
even vaguely understand those concepts
because history has become kind of about
humanities it's about progressive
visions and
finding kind of stimulating and um
extolling the virtues of voices that
haven't been heard
that's great that doesn't give us good
answers
to those big questions and bruce you
know
we we're talking about bad history and
so on and so forth a few months ago
there we there was a statue of edward
colston who was a
british slaver that was pulled down in
bristol i don't know if
you were following this at the time
where do you stand on that that we are
reappraising these historical figures
looking at them and for instance in the
case of edward coulson who was involved
in the slave trade made a lot of money
from it
should he have his stature in a
prominent place and if we're doing that
aren't we celebrating his crimes
well i i think um let me give you a
very pedantic answer but
he should be there if
the process of decision making in
bristol
through which it is decided what should
be where in public space
uh says he should be there and if the
process of decision making results in
the decision he shouldn't be there then
he shouldn't be there i mean
it's i don't think i don't think we can
have a big deductive
philosophical claim that he must be
there if the people of bristol don't
want him there then he shouldn't be
there
um and if um uh
the protesters uh led uh to a change of
heart by the city councilors
uh that's that statue shouldn't be there
i have no problem with that i mean
public spaces change all the time and
things that people like and don't like
get
removed and added and that's fine that's
what the public space is for
um of course if that had been someone's
private property displaying an
edward coulson statue and they had
invaded the private property
and uh defaced and destroyed that well
that's
a legal issue because that has to do
with property rights and that would be
wrong
unless the property owner also had a
change of heart and decided to take it
down
but that's fine that's within their
right so i i don't i don't like
putting a lot of analytical weight on
these statuary issues
because to me uh
it doesn't really matter whether his
statute is there in terms of the big
debate and
right and wrong indeed i would argue
that i would much prefer these great
statues
to be in a safe place where people can
learn about them than in the public
with a bunch of 20-something thugs uh
defacing them with
with spray paint every day um i have no
problem
with democratic processes which lead to
changes in public spaces consistent with
the mores and preferences of the
population affected
and what do you think about this wider
trend though of reappraising historical
figures
and judging them with the values of our
time for instance you know gandhi is now
a racist and so on and so forth
we always knew gandhi was a racist the
only people who didn't know gandhi was a
racist were the people who have gandhi
bumper stickers on their cars
and keep making up things like you know
always recycle your plastic bags gandhi
you know
you know he just he became a totem and
he was so
ripe for destruction um gandhi of course
was a very loyal
member of the british empire and uh
served in british forces in south africa
in world war
one um until he discovered he could make
a name for himself by being
anti-colonial
um but yes uh i i have again no problem
with gandhi's statue being
reappraised and those responsible for a
space in which his statue is displayed
uh having decision-making power to
remove it
um and following the processes of
democratic decision making through which
these decisions are made
coming to the conclusion that it's being
taken down and sent somewhere else i
have no problem with that i mean
no one has a no statute has a right to
the public square
that's different from the history itself
right which is
uh we need to and must continue to have
open-minded debates that include the
possibility of saying
churchill lord lugard um
a slave trader right uh have
a aspect of their biographies we should
we should value
we should honor um and be historically
understanding about the context in which
they operated
that's the history debate got nothing to
do with the statuary
and bruce let's move on to the other
aspect of all of this because
let's say i'm listening to you and i
fundamentally disagree with every single
thing that you said
right even if that were the case
i would still think that it's perfectly
legitimate for your work
to be published to be peer reviewed to
be criticized by your peers
who are qualified to talk about history
to say that bruce gilley doesn't know
what he's talking about
here's some counter evidence here's the
counter argument here are the facts
of the matter and for that to be a
process of academic debate
discussion etc but that doesn't seem to
to be what's happened in your case why
do you think the people who disagree
with you which i'm sure are many people
why can't they just do that well as you
say there's there's two types of
critics there's the critics who say
bruce i think you really got it wrong
you know i think i think the evidence is
not in your favor but uh
i will support your right to say it
because i i realize that you
refer to evidence that you use logic
um and that there's a lot of scholars
who have produced things saying exactly
the same that you've said
and as one harvard scholar said to me
after the case for colonialism article
he said bruce you know if you hadn't
read written that article someone else
would have
because it's been brewing for a long
time brewing for a long time was that
the phrase he used meaning there's been
a counter a revisionist literature
growing and someone was going to
summarize it and say hey
this this kind of uh
treatment of colonialism as a unique you
know western columbia unique historical
evil is just
uh really so one-sided we need to have
that other counter argument okay
then there's the other critics who say
this argument is so noxious
so offensive as sahar khan at the cato
institute
claimed in one of the most widely read
critiques
that it can't be heard and i'm not a
sensor
it's because we need to uphold academic
standards and some things
are so offensive and so beyond the pale
and so
inconsistent with the research
is is even to entertain them even to
give them a platform
is to engage in a kind of academic
misconduct right we are the guardians
of truth and the guardians of truth have
a gatekeeping role
and sometimes we just need to keep
barbarians outside of the gates
so uh two types of critics right and
the former i am completely comfortable
with indeed uh as i tell them you know
much of my research on this topic draws
upon people who disagree with me but i
respect their scholarship
because they provide evidence and facts
that are transparent enough to allow me
to draw different conclusions from
no problem with them most of the those
people are signing the petition in my
favor right now
uh it's the the the cancel culture
mob right who is found in very prominent
positions
uh and you can find their names they're
the ones
who seems to me feel insecure
about their premises because they have
responded
with such virile
attacks on me and my scholarship is it
makes you wonder
why do you feel so insecure and bruce do
you think that the
attacks would have been any less
vitriolic if you weren't a white man uh
well of course i don't think there would
have been attacks if i hadn't been a
white man because
um i can give you a half a dozen
scholars who are not white who have said
what i've said um and it just kind of
passes under the radar i think
my new book on german colonialism i'm
going to show you how much pushback
there has been among africanist scholars
scholars in africa
right black african scholars pushing
back
against the anti-german colonial
historiography of mostly white germans
in germany so yes that's you know
absolutely a part of the dynamic here
um it's also i think that you know
to be frank i do have privilege
and what one of my sets of privilege is
is
nobody can attack me for uh
violating the norms of my tribe right
and a lot of these scholars in places
like pakistan
right we actually the book series that
got cancelled we had a very interesting
proposal from a pakistani scholar
rewriting macaulay you know the story of
macaulay in a very
arguing that mccauley has been
misunderstood by anti-colonial scholars
well
he's now scared to death um because he
was submitting a proposal i've told him
you're safe i've
told anyone about this but you know
they have this problem that this can be
a life life-and-death
choice for them to step outside of the
anti-colonial
uh safe space um and so
one of the privileges of not being in
one of those tribes
is i have the role of speaking out
and yes the vitriol that attends that
we've spoken to
many people not not just nigel but other
academics who've
been cancelled you know had their
careers curtailed and they all seem to
make a similar point that
it's not just about what's happened to
them it's fundamentally damaging to
their subject
because it means that certain lines of
questioning can't be explored which
means that the subject can't be
progressed
do you think the same thing has happened
to history yeah and i i
i think this is fundamental and i think
what you have seen this summer
uh since a drug-addled felon
who had just robbed a store and was then
arresting resisting arrest
uh died because of his drug overdose in
minneapolis
tells you what's at stake here and you
know i'm sorry to make it so plain but
but this is what's at stake
you don't think he was killed by the
police officer bruce
uh so he died of a heart attack
and and he did not die of asphyxiation
yes the police officer was restraining
him in a way
that is not a good form of policing
and uh it was a violation of minneapolis
police protocols
uh and should be subject to discipline
for the manner in which he died i have
no problem with that
but uh but the reason for his death
according to the coroner was he had a
heart attack
um and he was having a heart attack long
before he was put on the ground
and his neck uh placed under that
officer's knee he was having a heart
attack when they were trying to get him
into the car
and he was resisting arrest right i mean
so i go back to
people were like well there's george
floyd i said let's look at george floyd
let's look at this this this
is this is the hero of your movement
right
um this is this is problematic and i
think there's a lot more at stake here
you know when i talk about what's at
stake why am i spending time arguing
about
lord lugard because this is where it's
coming out in the wash
right and and what is at stake here is
and this happened in britain this is
happening in canada this is happening in
australia
once you allow a distortionary account
of your national past to seize the high
ground
in the national discussion there becomes
a level of hatred and a level of
dissonance in your society
that will very quickly spill out into
social
chaos and i don't mean social chaos is
bad if people are protesting against
things but but what's happened
is a loss of faith in the structures of
democratic government and liberal
society itself
and where does that come from that comes
from this kind of historiography that
says
oh all your highfalutin language about
democracy and good governance
that was just a cover for exploitation
and oppression and racism
and so when you tell us we were we were
called to this store
to deal with a robbery and we found
ourselves in a difficult situation and
yes
this is not ideal policing and yes he
died and yes this is
uh the subject investigation oh this is
a whitewash
we're tearing the place down so so
black neighborhoods black businesses
black lives have been lost at an
alarming rate
in the last four months not just the
united states but elsewhere
because of a movement that grew out of
what is this fundamentally distortionary
account
of liberal society and i think a lot is
at stake here this is not just about
obscure historical arguments this is
about the foundations of a liberal
society and whether we should understand
them as basically good
or basically bad in other words what
you're saying and i'm not sure
in terms of george floyd i just from my
perspective what i understand was
that was the initial coroner's report
there was since an autopsy done by
someone else which
suggests that it was asphyxiation but
i'm it doesn't really matter too much
in terms of what you're saying because
if my understanding of what you're
saying is
if we tell ourselves stories full
stories
about how bad we are and how bad our
history is
then it almost makes sense to tear that
down yeah i mean
you know i mean the the world media and
the bbc
love and australian media too they love
these kind of
uh tv nightly news reports
america at war with itself right i mean
there's just a kind of ghoulish
fascination for watching um american
violence on the streets but look in your
own backyard
uh you know i'm canadian and um the cbc
loves
you know stories about um
protests in the u.s but meanwhile you
know alberta and saskatchewan want to
secede
uh quebec is going to probably have
another referendum
um this is a country falling apart
because it has been victimized by the
same sort of narratives
about its evil colonial settler colonial
past
as inspired protests and violence in the
united states
so this is a global phenomena
and it's rooted in a global set of
claims
that have dominated the academy and
therefore
spread into society at large and in
particular into elite and media culture
for the last 50 years
and the chickens are coming home to
roost and so so what do you think is
going to is the end game of this
particular movement bruce
well at a certain point um
reality clicks in right you do get
mugged by reality so um
so to take a very close example to me
um there was a girl raped in our
neighborhood
this summer in portland and
the family there's a big blm supporter
with signs and everything
the police said sorry we don't have time
to investigate this because every night
we're downtown
protesting you know dealing with
protesters and we're backed up
we can't investigate your daughter's
rape okay so a certain point
those who seek to tear down liberal
civilization
and the police and democratic procedures
and the economies that support our
flourishing
realize they're shooting themselves in
the foot they start to suffer the
consequences themselves
right and i you know i i hate to say
this but i think the only way
for this movement to arrest itself is to
discover the consequences
of what it's doing right and black
businesses are the first to feel this
right now black communities in the us
where murder rates are skyrocketing
thanks to the blm movement
are starting to discover this too so i
mean this is basically the revolutionary
process right we can trace this in every
revolution um
at a certain point you get to the point
of thermador and the backlash
and the reaction but in this case the
reaction is really just
maybe we do need police maybe we do need
to fund our police
maybe our police should be investigating
rapes instead of trying to keep a bunch
of delinquents
from destroying our federal courthouse
do you think that's the only
way out of a bruce there's no positive
way the only way is essentially is to
let let people create sort of chances
all over the united states go there for
a few days
if they make it out alive they come back
a little bit
uh with with a little bit more
perspective let's say on this whole
issue is that the only way
is there no way we can talk about this
well i you know i
again i'm i'm a big supporter of um
liberal fixes such as let's reinvigorate
debate
let's make sure we all adhere to
democratic procedures
let's make sure our protest is peaceful
uh
let's ensure that uh diversity of
political viewpoints are present in the
places where people are learning about
the facts
so i love that and that's um obviously a
program i'm fully on board with i think
what i've written about my own book
being canceled
in the wall street journal this week is
i'm starting to maybe just because i'm
getting old but
and and like thomas soul the great black
economist at stanford
starting to wonder if we're not reaching
a point of no return
and at that point with the ship sinking
i'm not sure the bucket brigade is
enough anymore right
um we need some more radical attempts
to keep this thing afloat and
the sort of liberal fixes to a
totalitarian problem
don't always work just ask the people
who had to flee the russian revolution
and bruce this is a question that i seem
to be asking almost
every episode but how much
responsibility do the universities need
to take for this
well i i'm not sure we can ask the
response the universities if by that you
mean the faculty and the administrators
to fix this problem because they are the
problem
um i do think that the chancellors
and the boards of trustees or boards of
governors
and the departments of education
that oversee the standards
and the funding the
uh rules um that govern these
institutions do have to take
responsibility
um it won't come from within the
university
the university is the problem um very
sorry to interrupt uh francis is a lefty
so when he said who should take
responsibility what he meant is who
should be punished
oh i see who should take responsibility
well you know i
i i don't blame anyone i don't think
anyone did wrong i mean
if i'm uh if i'm a young scholar and i
want to get a job in the english faculty
i will most assuredly write dissertation
on a
hitherto undiscovered black
transgender woman who had her land
stolen
and how we need to elevate that voice
and i'll get a job
well good on you you know i mean you you
had a system put before you
that was institutionalized and you acted
in response to those incentives and
you got to where you want that's that's
great i i
you know why why would we say that's
unfair that's the whole the whole idea
of property rights is
that people have reasonable expectations
that are created by a system
and you can't blame them when they hit
the jackpot um
however over time we need to change
those incentives
and uh the people who are responsible
are the people who are essentially
asleep at the wheel boards of trustees
chancellors of universities
departments of education or education
secretaries
especially when they are representing a
government that
is let's say center or center right
where we know that their constituents
want the university system to be changed
they
should take responsibility because they
failed to enact their
their jobs to make sure that
universities like all other parts
of federally funded or state-funded or
government-funded institutions
follow the expectations of democratic
majorities
well bruce thank you so much for your
time we're wrapping up so
we've just got one more question for you
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about as a society
but we really should be i think we need
to talk
about what is the end game for this
because it seems the more information we
have the more debate the more podcasts
the more
blogs the more difficult it is going to
be for us to understand
why people have different perspectives
on issues and
surely we don't want to tear ourselves
apart each time we discover a
disagreement
we're not talking about the in some ways
evolutionary flaw in our brains
that was really brains which were
designed to deal with groups of
60 or 70 people and are now interacting
with
several billion people simultaneously we
have to find a better way of responding
to things we disagree with or that we
find offensive
because i do think humanity's at stake
that's a really good point bruce thank
you so much for joining us
if people want to follow your case or
support you in any way what do they do
my twitter handle is bruce gilley3 and
that probably gets you all you need to
know
all right fantastic thank you so much
and thank you for watching we will see
you very shortly with another
episode or a live stream all of them go
out at 7pm uk time
absolutely they do wednesday and sunday
for our episodes
and tuesday thursday friday and saturday
for our live streams
we'll see you soon guys thanks for
watching guys
as always subscribe to the youtube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified
when a video comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word